you remember my next guest Jack Phillips
he's that Colorado Baker whose case went
all the way to the Supreme Court after
he refused to make a wedding cake for a
gay couple back in 2012. he said it
would have violated his first amendment
rights to religious liberty his
Christian faith he won on that narrow
ground but
he's now back in court fighting a
different battle but it's related after
refusing to make a transgen gender
birthday cake
yes apparently those exist lawyer Autumn
scardina wanted a pink cake with blue
frosting to celebrate the transition
from male to female
the Colorado Court of Appeals last week
ruled that Philip's refusal to make
scardina's cake did not constitute free
speech and that it was illegal to refuse
services to someone based on sexual
orientation Jack Phillips owner of
masterpiece cake shop joins me now along
with Aaron Hawley senior counsel at
Alliance defending freedom
Jack your reaction now more than a
decade after you first Tangled uh with
the radicals on this about this ruling
and your next steps
well first of all I just want to make it
clear that at masterpiece cake shop we
serve everybody who comes into our shop
but we can't create every cake that
people ask us to create because of the
messages that those cakes might Express
their custom artwork
and the this attorney uh Autumn scardina
called us up the day that the court
announced that they were going to take
our case the U.S Supreme Court back in
2017 and asked for the cake that you
described a cake that was pink in the
inside and blue on the outside and told
us that those colors were symbolic of
changing from a male to a female and at
that point that cake became a message
and we told scardina that this was a
message that we couldn't Express with
our custom art and we would be glad to
serve this attorney anything else in our
shop make other custom work but we
couldn't create that's this one so that
wasn't good enough the attorney went to
the Colorado Civil Rights Commission and
filed a complaint and they filed charges
against me and sued me right after the
Supreme Court had reprimanded the Civil
Rights Commission for their
impermissible hostility the first
go-around when they compared my
beliefs to slavery in the Holocaust
calling them yeah well you're being
targeted Aaron Aaron I'm a you know I'm
a I'm a lawyer you're being targeted
they they think you're a threat you're a
bigger threat than Al Qaeda or any
criminal cartel you are the threat they
think so the trial court Aaron found
that
um scardina called with actual intent to
purchase the cake and then the court
determined that it wasn't a setup to
initiate litigation just happens to be
the same Baker I mean
your reaction to that I mean it was
requested right on the same day that the
Supreme Court announced it would hear
Jack's original wedding cake case back
in 2017 it was kind of an anniversary
deal
I mean it doesn't make that it doesn't
pass the straight face test here
no that that seems like a bit of a
stretch and really Laura there's so much
wrong uh with the court of appeals
decision here uh if you look at this
case it fits squarely within the
Contours of 303 creative another Free
Speech case out of Colorado that shows
the Extreme Measures Colorado is going
to to suppress and coerce artists like
Jack like Lori Smith to speak and until
the Supreme Court is clear that all
artists whether it's a mom on Etsy who's
trying to make a little more money
whether it's Jack Phillips who's
designing beautiful cakes or Lori Smith
who's creating custom websites all
artists should be free to express what
they believe and government should not
be allowed to coerce them into saying
something that's contrary to those
beliefs
Well Jack a few months later there was
another cake that this Gardena character
requested that you make which you also
refused what was that
well the the cake in question this time
was a cake with depicting Satan smoking
marijuana and scardina has admitted in
court that these cakes were to correct
the errors of my thinking and it was a
setup and it was intentional and it was
staged in a specific way and scardina
also swore under oath that if I win this
case or if it's dis dismissed the very
next day I would get another phone call
with another cake and we would start all
over again and the court seemed to
ignore that or not hear that part Aaron
the the bottom line here Beyond this
particular case in my view is that
the left wants to drive Christians out
of the Public Square at all I'm like you
don't even have a right to have a small
business if you're a Christian today you
certainly don't have any conscience
rights you have no religious liberty
rights you have no First Amendment
rights if you clash with a what they
believe to be a you know the supremely
protected Among Us do you feel that
that's where we're headed here
um I think that's definitely a danger
here a win for Lori is a win for
everyone because it protects everyone as
rights to free speech like Mr Phillips
here
Jack and Aaron we're going to be
following this as usual thank you both